I'd like to now take a few moments to talk about how
to be a good ciziten on the Internet. There are two key
things you can do, when you’re writing programs to manipulate other peoples
websites, or to access other peoples websites, that will make everybody's life a
lot easier. One is, use a good user agent. Remember, we talked
about, in unit one, user agents are the header that describe what,
what browser you are using, or what program you are using to
access somebody. If you are planning
on accessing somebody in a consistent fashion.
If you're going to polll them, you know, every couple of seconds for
updates or do something like that, use a good user-agent. When you're using
urllib2 you can specify headers in your request, and you should set a
user-agent header that says, you know, who you are, what your name is, maybe
links to your website. So that somebody on the other end, if they
see you, you know, pounding them with lots and lots of requests, they
know, they know what's up. They have a way of reaching you to
ask you to stop or to tell you they blocked you or that sort
of thing. It's good to always include that. And the other important thing is,
is to rate-limit yourself. If you want to download, let's say, all of the
search results for the word udacity on Twitter, yeah, you can, you can request
them 15 at a time, which is what their API returns, I believe. As fast
as you can, but you'd be really sending a lot of requests to Twitter
because you can have some loop and it's much, much faster than any human
could type it and that will actually hurt Twitter's service. If you were to
have code like this in Python, you
know, while there's more stuff, make another request
to Twitter, and just run this and this infinite loop, or maybe
not infinite loop, but loop that's going to run through a number of
iterations, you'd be sending requests as fast as Twitter could possibly serve
them. Instead it's a really good to get in the habit of using
the sleep function. In Python you can say import time, time.sleep(1). And
this will cause your interpreter to sleep for one second. And this
is nice. Then you're only hitting them once a second, which is
much more sustainable. But, if you abuse their service, or do too many
requests, they'll probably rate-limit you. I
know Twitter does. Because I thought about
having a quiz in this, in this unit that was, how many requests
in a minute can you make before Twitter rate-limits you? But then I
realized that that would be the exact opposite of being a good citizen
on the net, asking thousands of students to go hit some website as
fast as you can. It's generally not a nice thing to do. So,
instead, we're just going to talk about it. I'm going to ask you
to make sure, if you're hitting somebody hard, that you structure your code
like this. Include a sleep so you pause
a little bit and don't hit anybody too hard.